[Music]
inmates singing their prayers grateful
for serving their sentences far from
Brazil's violent and overcrowded
Penitentiary system
leading the choir is part of Israel
Domingo's daily routine in this model
prison run by a non-profit organization
in the state of Minnesota
the 34 year old confit has spent half
his life in and out of jail for
attempted murder armed robbery and drug
trafficking
I used to live with 80 inmates in a Cell
built for 30. like most convicts I spent
my time thinking about the crimes I'd
commit when I was released but not
anymore
here Domingos has the key to the key
tell in a
by Gardens with
armed guards
it's a far cry from Brazil's typical
jails where inmates lived in crammed
spaces often without mattresses adequate
hygiene or food
eighty percent of Brazilian inmates fall
back into crime whereas in our system
less than 20 percent of them relapse
there are 64 facilities like ours in the
country that are funded by the
government but cost a fifth the amount
of a normal jail because we spend money
on education instead of weapons and
guards
350 prisoners live here 70 of them women
like Maria Laura benevuto convicted of
manslaughter
I couldn't believe it when I was ordered
to take off my handcuffs and switch my
uniform for ordinary clothes
studying and working are mandatory
inmates make their own food and learn
skills like carpentry and mechanics
if the system works so well why aren't
there more model prisons in Brazil one
reason is that people living in the city
are reluctant to have jails with no
locks next door
says local acceptance is essential to
the project we faced a lot of resistance
at first people want criminals locked up
and Far Away unless the criminal is part
of their family that's why it's also
necessary to have a judge committed to
the project it's up to the judge to
decide who qualifies for the model
prison
prerequisites are good behavior in a
long sentence so inmates have time to
finish their rehabilitation program
Domingos has served half of his seven
year sentence he's finishing his legal
studies but hopes to make a career as a
singer Monica yanakev Al Jazeera songs
Brazil